trinken macht man count davon 32
was geht ab was glaubt netz bekommen
beim ein video das heutige video wird
unterstützt von pit und zwar ist dass
dieses produkt was jetzt gleich mal
ausprobieren werden wir haben uns da was
mega witziges überlegt also ich hoffe es
wird lustig das teil hat nämlich echt
geile sachen drauf ist gut gemacht
und bevor er fragt ihre haare sehr kalt
geduscht deswegen sind die nassen war
beim letzten haben viele gesagt das
fertige haare ok auf jeden fall willst
du das einmal vorführen was das alles
drauf hat also das gibt so befehle ab
und dann muss man diese befehle
ausführen köpfen verstärken mein bruder
ist übrigens auch noch dabei mit dem
spiel mit gleichen runde mehr spieler
und wir haben ja drei bestrafungen erst
bestrafung für die einbuße setzen
das sind so eklige boni nach
vertrockneten füßen oder so schmecken
oder nach hundefutter oder eine
babywindel härtester winter dann noch
eine bestrafung schlag ins gesicht und
eine kartoffel also einmal reinbeißen
reicht würde ich mal sagen weil dies
halt nicht gemacht die waren nicht in
wasser was heißt sondern einfach eine
rohe kartoffel ich zeige euch einmal
wieder zeit funktioniert wollte flotten
sechseinhalb stunden später hallo hallo
hallo alex
228 nacht habe ich auch genau räder die
eigentliche fehler vorher also deutet
die erste runde spielt jetzt einfach
gegen meine freundin wer mehr schafft
und der verlierer muss eine von diesen
bestrafung machen und die zweite runde
stimme zusammen im mehrspielermodus das
werden wir gleich sehen mit meinem
bruder zusammen
und der verlierer muss die bestrafung
machen also schnick schnack schnuck
blocken
der hatte boston page baby also ich muss
jetzt 34 schaffen
35 glocken um eine abschaffung der fünf
tomaten essen ich es wenigstens eine
tomate jetzt nicht fünf tomaten ernten
ich hasse tomaten 200
das ist okay ich als 100 schiffe jetzt
kommt zur nummer zwei
und zwar sind wir zu dritt mein bruder
ist auch noch dabei um ich bin jetzt zu
dritt im mehrspielermodus
ihr werdet es gleich verstehen man muss
das einfach immer sofort weitergeben
also der sagt dann weitergeben und dann
muss das nicht sein diese befehle waren
dann sagt er wieder weitergeben und bei
dem der halter nicht schafft wo es
aufhört
der hat verloren so leute wie ging jetzt
ein mehrspielermodus spieler ok zu
anfang kämen zu spät
das darf mir aussuchen ich habe jetzt
gerade mich frisch gemacht und erkennst
du hast schon durch mein körper
umzusteigen
ich bin für den kranken du aber doch
nicht hier natürlich alex das jetzt mit
dem kuchen also leute wir haben hier als
bestrafung quark ins gesicht läuft das
runter macht man count davon 32
von der hand warum nicht ganz kurz
android home an handtuch
ich habe doch gesagt wir können es
besser im bad machen heute das war's mit
diesem video wir hoffen natürlich es hat
euch gefallen lassen daumen nach oben da
wenn das der fall ist auf jeden fall
könnt ihr jetzt noch uns heraus von ich
glaub das höchste was erreicht wurde war
von ma 34 und wenn ihr jetzt auch zum
beispiel denkt über doppeltes geil ich
mache das auch dann laden doch einfach
ein video hoch mit eurem bob wird sei es
auf instagram sei es auf youtube
facebook keine ahnung gibt ja so viel
und schickt mir dass ich gucke wirklich
jedes video an und der der meisten
wiederholung oder am meisten dessen
heißt am höchsten ist der bekommt noch
eine fette überraschung von mir
ansonsten noch mal danke doppelt für die
kooperation des echten witziges ding und
ja wir sehen uns dann morgen oder
übermorgen 19 uhr neues video hat rein
sobald hier noch was sagen zum abschluss
hat spaß gemacht